the math itself completely debunks the
mainstream explanation for how the
ancient Egyptians were able to construct
the Great Pyramid of Giza and how long
it took them to do so and in this video
I'm gonna share with you a few short
video clips of the most common methods
described by mainstream archaeologists
Egyptologists and academics for how the
ancient Egyptians were able to cut and
carve these stones so you can see
firsthand with your own eyes just how
flawed these methods truly are now
depending on what source you look at the
timeframes vary on how long it took the
ancient Egyptians to construct the Great
Pyramid of Giza ranging from ten to
thirty years
however twenty years is the most
commonly accepted timeframe into what
they teach in school twenty years to cut
carve move and perfectly place
approximately 2.5 million stone blocks
that's equivalent to one block every two
minutes in six seconds the precision of
these two and a half million stone
blocks is incredible
not even a razor or a pin needle can fit
between them and just to remind
ourselves each block has six sides I
don't mean to be patronizing but just as
a visual reminder that each block would
have had to been perfect on all six
sides and although the size of these
stone blocks did vary the average size
was 50 inches by 50 inches by 27 and you
can see here the metric conversion on
the screen but this of course does not
include some of the blocks that are
absolutely massive to give us a better
appreciation of the massive scale of the
Great Pyramid it's more than 755 feet
long at its base and is made up of more
than 200 layers and each layer had to be
absolutely perfect each block had to be
laid down in place down to a fraction of
a millimeter otherwise the entire
pyramid would not have been nearly as
precise as it is out of these two and a
half million stone blocks a significant
majority of them are made up of
limestone and one of the most common
methods described by Egyptologists is
that the Egyptians use stone hammers and
bronze chisels to cut and carve these
stones and real quick if you're not
familiar bronze is a makeup of copper
and tin let me jump into the first video
clip which includes mark Lehner one of
the most leading authorities on
Egyptology and the works of the pyramids
and the Sphinx and you'll find his
name cited in almost every single
textbook throughout the world regarding
these subjects in this video you'll see
that they tried and cut and carve one
limestone block down to half the size of
the great Sphinx's nose in real quick
you'll see some sub captions in this
video those are not my words that's when
the person that uploaded this and I'll
include the link to that seven-minute
video in the description however I edit
it down to show just the highlights in
this clip is about 55 seconds long here
we go but even with reinforcements and
after hours of pounding they barely made
a dent after days of work their copper
chisels and stone pounders are barely
making a dent
Brown is wearing down tools at an
extraordinary rate the copper chisel the
ancient Egyptians would have used lasts
only a few dozen strikes the heating
pounding cycle is repeated over and over
I'm ready
yep until the shape is just right they
must have amassed more copper for
building the Great Pyramid in the Sphinx
and just about any place in the world in
the 3rd millennium BC I mean it just
must have been a huge cost in confidence
Wow
so just a few dozen strikes per chisel
and then you saw how long it takes them
to reshape this thing I mean heating it
and cooling it several times an
incredibly lengthy period of time and
you heard mark Lehner himself discuss
how the Egyptians would have had a
massive amount of copper chisels which
hasn't been found and I'll touch on that
point later in this video and by the way
they didn't even finish this project
they brought in power tools and it took
professionals more than two weeks to cut
and carve this nose now like I mentioned
a significant majority of the Great
Pyramid is made up of limestone blocks
however the internal structure is made
up of granite this includes the internal
passageways the massive Grand Gallery
the Queen's Chamber as well as the
King's Chamber itself and these blocks
many of them are more than 70 tons and
seemingly have laser-cut precision so
here's a quick 20 second clip on using
bronze chisels on granite which is
significantly stronger than limestone
when Raja tries chiseled made from
bronze the results disappointing metal
and very little stone is played so
regardless of whether we're talking
limestone or granite the bronze chisel
stone hammer theory is debunked it
doesn't make sense it doesn't compute
based on the time and the precision so
this brings me back to the question on
where are all the bronze chisels now why
have they found so few I'm trying to
find a specific number but have they
found even more than a few dozen of
these things throughout the entire
country of Egypt I mean if anyone has a
specific number please share I've been
trying to research this for myself
but clearly they would have had to have
had hundreds of thousands of these tools
I mean two dozen strikes per chisel and
it takes much longer than most people
realize to reshape it I think the most
logical explanation and why they're not
finding so many bronze chisels is the
fact they just weren't using these as
the primary method to cut and carve tens
of millions of stone blocks this brings
me on to a more common and popular
theory which is utilizing copper and
bronze saws to cut through these stones
and as you can see here these are
clipart images provided by Egyptologists
on the theory of using copper saws to
cut through stone so let me show you the
next video clip that shows them trying
to utilize copper saws on granite
alright we have a big block of granite
here so how's this copper gonna cut this
granite even with teeth the copper alone
is too soft we're going to put sound
inside the groove and we're going to put
this saw on top of the sound and then
let the Sun do the cutting now Dennis
will we see any progress in our lifetime
yes if you came back in an hour's time
you would see about a full millimeter
drop down into the stone you're kidding
in an hour you'll be four millimeters
down well I've been doing a lot of
experiments and I can guarantee that
this will cook through the stone that's
about one of the meats as an hour sorry
went wonderful once we switched over to
using water with the sand as you can see
here we achieved this in just a few days
four millimeters an hour that's
equivalent to about one-sixth of one
inch and although they said it went much
quicker while using water they didn't
specify how much quicker I mean was it
twice as fast was it even that much this
just assumed that it was six times as
fast so one inch an hour
that still doesn't compute whatsoever
and this doesn't include the fact that
they've never found a copper saw of this
size anywhere throughout ancient Egypt
in fact you don't even find any
depictions of it through wall paintings
hieroglyphs petroglyphs no we're in fact
the only art that you'll find is just a
few different images where they have
these smaller copper saws and they
utilize them to cut wood and as you can
see here here's the best example I could
find of a copper saw and look at that
that's not even a
foot blade is that even 18 inches maybe
20 inches altogether and we're supposed
to believe that these small saws and
I'll show you more examples of them in
just a moment we're used to cut and
carve even an average-sized block I mean
never mind the much larger stone blocks
around throughout the Pyramid of Giza
but again that video is showing you
cutting through granite so let me show
you a different video clip of people
using hand saws to cut through limestone
blocks and although this video has
nothing to do with Egyptology and
whatsoever these are just some
old-school guys that show you that you
can use hand saws to cut through
limestone well here's the video clip
[Music]
[Music]
so a couple notable points right off the
bat is did you see how long those saws
were they must have been longer than
five feet not to mention they were not
made up of copper whatsoever and also
take a look at the aggressive crosscut
teeth if he saws had clearly the ancient
Egyptians had nothing like this there's
not one single bit of evidence to
suggest it and it's worth mentioning
that the finished product isn't perfect
at all I mean yeah there are some very
straight lines but when you look at the
block as a whole it's just not perfect
so they would have had to gone back over
it with what bronze chisels again
another point worth mentioning is how
difficult the sign becomes when you get
down to the base of the block I mean
take for example the limestone quarry
located right there on the Giza Plateau
imagine what I mean that's right on
bedrock look how little room you have to
work with
how could you cut the base of that stone
block and not to mention as you see here
these other examples of these bronze
saws found throughout ancient Egypt I
mean they're incredibly short none of
them exceed 2 feet long and I'm under
the impression I mean have they even
found a dozen of these things ever does
anyone have an estimate these are all
the examples I could find pictures of
but it really raises a lot of questions
clearly this method just does not
compute and not to mention the complete
lack of evidence to support it are we
supposed to believe that this would have
been a method utilized to be able to cut
carve move in place perfectly one block
every two minutes in six seconds
guys it doesn't add up let me transition
into another example which is utilizing
wood wedges that are soaked in water in
order to split apart massive stone
blocks and there is evidence of this as
you can see here these are examples from
the Aswan quarry which is about 500
miles from the great pyramids first it
must be mentioned that the soap would
would not provide nearly as a precise
cut as using chisels so in modern times
you can see people doing it here in
these examples these photos but the end
product does not justify the incredible
precision of the stone blocks at the
Great Pyramid of Giza are we supposed to
believe that they would have gone back
over that stone block with bronze
chisels and copper saws all over again
when we've already seen that those
methods don't work anyhow and not to
mention a complete lack of evidence on
the Giza Plateau to support that this is
the method that they were utilizing yes
the ancient Egyptians did do this we
have evidence at the Aswan quarry again
but nothing to justify two and a half
million stone blocks not at all and we
have to remind ourselves that we're only
discussing the Great Pyramid of Giza
there are between 118 and 138 pyramids
scattered throughout Egypt and in fact
this isn't even updated because as I
mentioned in other videos just earlier
this year they found an entirely new
pyramid in ruins under the sands of
Egypt which again raises all kinds of
questions but for hundreds of pyramids
we're talking tens of millions of stone
blocks and if they can't compute these
or finisher construct one pyramid in the
twenty thirty year time frame it
completely debunked the entire narrative
now I certainly don't think that
everything is a conspiracy or a cover-up
but we have to start asking serious
questions when the leading authorities
on the topic of Egyptology whose works
are published in textbooks all over the
world regarding the pyramids and the
Sphinx and these individuals have seen
firsthand with their own eyes that none
of these methods compute and yet they've
done nothing to bring this up or raise
the question of developing new theories
and asking new questions instead they
keep pushing the same narrative they're
teaching this in school right now
they're handing out PhDs with these
methods and nobody seems to be thinking
for themselves to just try them and to
make this even more disturbing this same
guy mark Lehner seems to be going along
with this 10-year time frame he's
doubling down instead of acknowledging
that these methods don't work he's going
along with a possible 10-year time frame
that's been discussed by other
Egyptologists what is going on it's time
we start asking serious questions about
it but I'll leave it at that leave me a
comment let me know what your thoughts
are but like and subscribe I'm Jimmy
this is bright insight many more videos
to come and a whole wide variety of
topics take care everybody